I gotta take a Dookie but I ain't gonna
do it you know why cuz I'm committed to
this [ __ ] vlog I'm holding that [ __ ]
in not you oh hey what's going on
YouTube what nah basically I've got an
article which makes me feel a little
weird not one because the subject topic
was really awkward it was weird because
of how everybody was reacting towards it
now you guys know about this acting a
Chris Pratt right Chris Pratt is
actually in one of my favorite Marvel
movies of all time
what I don't you know the [ __ ] name
guy was hilarious in the movie his
comedic timing is always on point
he's on Parks and Rec and on top of that
he was also in the Jurassic world movie
now in this article it stated that he
was losing a lot of fans because he
would not act or take a job without
taking money and it's the craziest
[ __ ] thing people are saying oh oh my
god I [ __ ] change my opinion about
this actor because he won't act for free
ah let me put this in perspective for
you [ __ ] alright asking though
you may not think it's a job it's a
[ __ ] job do you go to your 9:00 to
5:00 every day with your heart filled
with joy I'm just gonna do my wife for
free you know you expect a [ __ ]
paycheck but it's art you should be able
to do it for the willingness of your
heart as someone who was an amateur
actor and is trying acting for himself
that [ __ ] is not easy
you go through constant classes and
constant rejection and let me break down
to you what rejection is you go out to
these auditions and you know what these
auditions aren't these auditions are job
interviews so imagine going to about
seven [ __ ] job interviews a day for a
whole year and having everybody tell you
you're not good enough
for me if I paid my dues like that and
I'm finally in a successful position
where I can make money and I've been
doing things for free for years and
years yeah yeah [ __ ] damn straight I
ain't doing [ __ ] for free I don't
understand why are you so surprised that
people don't want to work for free just
because you glorified what somebody else
does does not take away from their hard
work no people always look at
entertainers as if their lifes are the
easiest [ __ ] things on earth and you
know for certain ones that may be true
never new people so said I'll somebody
getting paid for a job that blows my
[ __ ] mind
[ __ ] the next time I see you
won't get Burger King you better give me
surprise for free I don't want you to
wrap that burger up for a [ __ ]
paycheck I want you to do it out of the
case I'm your fan here's some real [ __ ]
when I understand it comedian and I
wasn't making [ __ ] and in fact I was
losing more money driving to these
comedy clubs than actually making money
they're limited um you get a little your
poor mother sucks the big I don't suck
dick but let me tell you something else
if it got that boy I feel like certain
people sometimes just write articles to
get people riled up and then what
happens is when you put stupid [ __ ] on
the internet you start to realize there
are more stupid people out on this earth
then there are smart people if you ask
me do I do things for free of course I
do things for free I'm a [ __ ] nobody
man give me something I'll do that [ __ ]
for free right now but you can't put me
in the bracket of real celebrity shaken
by my self-esteem lowers [ __ ] I'd do
anything baby we want you with this
movie how much I can't Bank five chicken
nuggets in a [ __ ] I stopped by there
are chicken nuggets all I need
[ __ ] I can see you there